Hello Freak bitches.
And it's been crazy,
but it then amazing Raj happen where I'm
at right now.
Oh,
let me tell you a boy joy everywhere I
go.
Well,
did you,
when did,
when did the social media thing kicking
my nephew,
craig?
Shout out to Craig Brown,
let's go chat whenever you crack.
Came about four years ago.
Um,
I had my first instagram account.
I was like,
it was just photos then.
And I was like,
you know what man,
I'm gonna lose this weight.
And uh,
it sounds like a corny thing to do and
was doing like a little blog,
but I'm going to just do my own,
you know,
even for myself.
And I put it up,
I had nine followers champ and it built
to like,
you know,
2000.
I was like,
man,
if I can ever get the 5,000
then you know,
I'll,
I'll be there and I'm,
I never paid for the followers.
And they went to this whole thing where
they dropped everybody with who would
pay for the followers.
I wanted to be in like 5,000.
I was like,
man,
if I ever get the 10,000
and then they came out with the video
and Craig came to town,
I was like,
Oh,
Craig,
I'm going work out every day and I want
you to film it and we're gonna put it on
instagram and see how it goes.
And it just took off.
But it's just hilarious how much is
taken out to care when I tell people
that you were going to be on man,
I'm telling you like,
not like anybody else that's ever been
on.
I've got a wave of people that got
excited about it.
I appreciate that because they don't
have a publicist champ.
Uh,
I do everything.
We do everything in house jam,
which is just me and Craig,
him and off my family.
We do everything and we don't have any,
uh,
marketing behind us.
Nothing.
We just try to hit grinding.
And,
uh,
fortunately,
we've let the shot now for this wba
every championship has been ordered as
far as Brian and the team.
They've been delaying.
Um,
I'm not sure if he's going to drop out
and just give me the belt.
I'm not sure what's happening because
we've been waiting for them to pull the
trigger.
They said they were going to,
you know,
find,
find the venue and everything is taught.
We talked about Australia,
they talked about China.
Who's the promoter?
Uh,
well,
you know,
his,
his management team and his lawyer,
Leon Michael,
Lisa handling most of it.
But if they don't come with the deal
champion,
basically,
I already feel like everybody's scared
of me.
So I didn't think he just gave me the
belt because I just want to fight
Klitschko to be honest with you,
cause I want to prove to the world that
he saw for the biscuit because he really
is.
I thought his brother went on for 12
rounds.
One off for 12 rounds.
This happened in the first round.
Joe and the first round.
Yeah,
in the first round,
not only tore the Bicep,
the tendon popped,
they had to go through both sides.
This was in the first year I took,
I took like unreal punches to the head.
I forgot how many number was,
but I took unreal punches to the head.
They left me for dad.
I ain't even get paid for the fight
champ.
What happened there?
How'd you knock your parents?
Listen,
I started,
I started the promotional company called
Golden Empire.
It was basically backdoor to change to
the empire.
We fought.
The company fell as though certain
things that were a lot of to me,
I don't know.
They said I had a tab.
It was crazy,
but the tide was never produced.
Um,
the company that I started basically
what's in my company anymore and I was
surprised I was supposed to be giving
shares.
This company wound up going to try and
trying to purchase EDC,
EDC,
electric,
daisy carnival to my introduction.
You've got crazy.
Were public.
The night before my fight,
the stock was up.
I had no shares.
I said,
I'm not signing nothing too.
I know I'm guaranteed a purse.
It was crazy chairman.
This would link to my depression.
It's why we're home after the fight and
was like,
Yo,
what happened to you?
I fought.
I've taught my fourth vitaly critical
for 12 rounds.
I took ass.
I ain't even get paid.
That's crazy.
And I was in court with them for eight
months before I settle out on like
pennies on the dollar because I had to
take care of my family chat and this is
what drove me to pure depression,
but then I overcame that and I'm here
with you.
How much did they fuck you out of a
chair?
Who knows?
I mean the fight.
This is facts.
This is facts jab like they say in New
York,
facts,
you feel me?
Listen,
it was the highest grossing fight as far
as TV coverage and history at either one
or two in German history.
Shannon breeds versus fatality clinical.
He's a huge star in German and I will
see you and I went over there now bought
action and the people was like,
Yo,
listen,
this guy can sell.
We'd want to see this fight.
The ratings were unreal.
It was like the highest rating in
history,
champ.
I ain't get $1.
That's so cool.
How can I,
how can I not fall into depression,
but how could I not come out of it?
I been fighting since day one channel.
I've been fighting a brief chat.
Yeah.